the first step is we can start two ways
we can start with a disease let's say we
want to think about transplant rejection
you try to think about what's happening
in the body in your cells at the
molecular level that's causing your body
to say yes I need this organ but I did
not make it it's not mine and I want
this foreign material out of here and
you think about what are the proteins
that are at work why are they doing that
and are there any proteins whose
function I can modify or change such
that they don't work to reject this
organ and so you start brainstorming
you're coming up with ideas what might
be happening you're looking at what's
known and trying to think about what a
what what are the points at which I can
go to try to to alter this and to figure
it out so that's where the basic process
actually begins I'll stay with the
transplant rejection example so this was
an idea that one of our researchers and
immunology came up with now he saw a
paper published about skid so skid is an
acronym for severe combined
immunodeficiency syndrome so most people
know it as Bubble Boy disease to bubble
boy movies John Travolta in the 70s and
the more recent one and basically what's
happening is that the immune system is
not functioning and there was a paper
published about mice that had the skid
disease and he had the idea if your
immune system is what's at work when
you're rejecting an organ and you have
us disease where the immune system is
not working and we found out because in
this paper they identified a particular
protein that wasn't functioning
properly in those animals so based on
just what we call the phenotype the
symptoms of that disease they were able
to I'd make a link between that protein
and that function so he thought can we
alter that proteins function in patients
who might be receiving transplants to
see if we can help them keep their
organs that transplanted organs
healthier and for a longer period of
time so that's one way an example where
that came about it's the combination of
finding out what's known and thinking
about what's known in new ways you know
that there's the element of creativity
you go what if and what comes after is
that the light bulb like what if we can
do that
you